- Extra sprouts and
no mayo.
My name's Amy.
She's cute.
- Yeah.
Wow, Freedom Tower is like
really coming along, huh?
God, I can't believe it's
been 12 years since 9/11.
- Oh my god, I know.
It's bananas, time really flies.
I can't remember, do they
take a long time here?
- No, they're
usually pretty quick.
- Okay.
- I was actually supposed
to be meeting my girlfriend
at the World Trade
Center that day.
I'm on like Walker Street,
and I hear this crazy noise,
but like I wasn't thinking
it was anything bad.
But then I look up--
- Allen, I'm just kind of
freaking out right
now, that I want mayo.
You know, I'm like why did
I act like I didn't want it?
(chuckles) But I don't
have to go talk to them.
I am so present and
here with you right now,
I can stay.
- Uh, well...
- Everything's cool.
They're gonna put mayo
on it, (chuckles) sorry.
Okay, so what's going on in
the story, what were you...
- The fireball.
- Ooh, right.
Keep going.
- Yeah, so, for hours I'm
like calling my girlfriend
and I can't get through to her.
- Oh my god, is that Dina Lohan?
Oh, it's like a pile of cups.
Sorry, what's happening?
- Yeah, I'm calling
my girlfriend,
and I can't, like
I can't reach her,
'cause all the cell
phones are jammed, and
everyone is trying to call--
- Verizon?
It's Verizon, right?
They cannot get it together.
It's been like 130 years, like,
like, help us out, help
us make a call, right?
(chuckles) Verizon, it's
like, run a business.
Can we stand over there?
I'm scared I'm not gonna
hear when they call my name,
and I want to keep an
eye on my sandwich.
- Yeah, sure.
(pop music)
It's loud over here.
- You thought she was dead?
- Yeah, so finally at like 8
pm, my girlfriend calls me,
but she's so hysterical,
I can barely understand
a word she's saying--
- Yeah, wait, speaking of that
can you just stop talking
for like one second?
I'm trying to Shazam a
song, it's like not tagging.
I think 'cause you're
talking to me, yeah.
I know it's Robin Thicke but I
don't know what Robin Thicke.
You know?
Oh, it's Pink.
I'm an idiot.
- [Server] Amy?
- Oh, thank you.
- Anyway, so she
made it out, but like
as they were running, they
heard these loud noises
and they realized that it--
- Oh my gosh!
They didn't put
mayo on my sandwich.
Why is my life the worst life?
- Do you want to take it back?
- No, I don't want them
to think I'm an asshole.
God, I'm in the worst
mood, and whatever.
- So where were you on 9/11?
- I don't remember.
(upbeat music)